bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
sur TVfil 78 voici les titres de ce 3
septembre incivilité violence à l'arraja
je le maire PCF de la verrière demande
une nouvelle fois un renforcement de la
présence policière dans certains
quartiers mais aussi des moyens à l'état
pour agir sur un plan social la route se
déportementale 30 qui relie plaisir et
Élancourt fréquemment embouteillée 20
enfin connaître des travaux
d'élargissement de voies supplémentaires
le chantier débute ce mois-ci l'équipe
de France 2 football revient dans les
Yvelines après son beau parcours lors du
Mondial brésilien les joueurs
rencontreront en amical l'Espagne jeudi
soir au Stade de France
l'actualité aujourd'hui 3 septembre
c'était la grande première du mercredi
matin travailler dans les écoles
publiques une nouveauté mise en place
dans le cadre de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires et accueillis plus ou moins
bien par les familles nous sommes allés
alors rencontre dans les communes de
plaisir et de Rambouillet là où la
classe le matin finit dorénavant à 11h54
un horaire très précis qui laisse
certains parents assez perplexe écoutez
c'est assez étonnant après que ce soit
bon 11h54 ou midi ça ne change pas grand
chose voilà il en a été décidé comme ça
c'est étonnant mais bon j'ai pas très
bien compris le 11h54 puis ça fait déjà
des grosses journées ça déjà 3h le matin
là ça leur fait une demi-heure de plus
ce que ça change pour moi déjà c'est
surtout au niveau des enfants de
l'élever cinq jours de suite par semaine
c'est toute une organisation je trouve
que c'est pas très bien parce que le
mercredi c'est une pause pour la semaine
donc voilà bah déjà vachement pour moi
c'est déjà plus d'écoles c'est bien et
en même temps ça va vite parce que vous
puis faire d'activités le mercredi matin
il va falloir qu'on s'arme de patience
trouver les nourrices avoir le
fonctionnement si les grands-parents
peuvent pas venir garder les petits
enfants l'organisation différente moi il
allait au centre de toute façon du matin
7h30 à 18h30 donc aujourd'hui c'est
exceptionnel que je viens de le chercher
mais il ira au centre quoi qu'il arrive
donc pour les gens comme moi ça change
absolument rien
le matin ça a changé ça on peut voir on
peut voir plus les copains et on peut
apprendre plein de choses aussi
éducation toujours c'est en ce moment
que je joue les derniers ajustements de
la carte scolaire en fonction des
effectifs dans les Yvelines dit classes
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes et de
fermetures prononcées depuis lundi
exemple à Trappes l'école maternelle du
berceau qui bénéficie d'une cinquième
classe encore l'école Curie d'une
huitième classe alors bonsoir vous êtes
le meilleur communiste de la ville de La
Verrière vous êtes l'invité du journal
ce soir avant de parler tout à l'heure
de votre nouvel appel à l'État afin
d'obtenir des moyens pour votre commune
pour mener une politique pour les
citoyens un mot sur cette rentrée
scolaire qu'on a abordé brièvement au
début du journal comment se mettre en
place les nouveaux rythmes dans votre
commune en termes de pas à 11h54 dans la
semaine j'ai déjà assez compliqué comme
ça si en plus nous donnons des des
horaires incompréhensibles pour les
enfants et pour les parents ça serait
difficilement la rentrée c'est plutôt
bien passée j'ai effectivement fait la
tournée avec sous préfet de Rambouillet
des écoles hier matin rencontrer les
enseignants les parents les enfants bien
accueillis on l'avait préparé en amont
sur ce plateau de ces activités qui sont
proposées aux enfants en dehors donc des
périodes scolaires certaines communes
ont fait le choix de la garderie vous
n'avez pas fait le choix on a fait le
choix d'activités diversifiées sportives
culturelles artistiques de détente de
découverte donc toute une panoplie par
cycle de 6 semaines qui correspondent
entre deux vacances scolaires et les
enfants tournent autour de ces de ces
ateliers que nous mettons en place donc
ça leur permet effectivement d'avoir des
nouveaux apprentissages des peut-être
aussi la le moyen de se mettre en valeur
de réussir c'est important
en plateau avec nous vous allez
découvrir comme les téléspectateurs la
suite de ce journal il est question à
présent d'urbanisme de transport après
des années d'hésitation le projet de
doublement de la RD30 prend forme de
Lourdes travaux à attendre un moyen de
relier le Nord et le Sud du département
les riverains sont inquiets clairs
Cambier et William L
depuis 20 ans le doublement de la RD30
est un projet mais aujourd'hui ça y est
cette aménagement devient réalité le but
fluidifier le trafic et décharger le
centre-ville de plaisir mais aussi
palier un manque de liaison routière
Nord-Sud dans le département on a toutes
les liaisons Est-Ouest qu'on veut à 14 à
13 national 12 national 10 tout ça
converge très bien vers Paris mais quand
on veut aller du nord du département au
sud ou du sud au nord bah là il y a pas
de route le projet a soulevé de
nombreuses inquiétudes dériverains il y
a encore quelques années les opposants
affichés clairement leur opposition
crainte d'un trafic accru d'un manque de
liaison avec les quartiers de plaisir et
de solutions de circulation douce
aujourd'hui aux alentours de la RD30 les
habitants restent mitigés déjà on a pas
mal de bruit et puis bon on a des on a
peur d'avoir des des soucis au niveau
des affaissements des maisons tout ça
quoi ça va décongestionner la route là
là parce que c'est toujours encombré les
enfants suivre l'accéder à traverser ils
peuvent plus alors ils ont dit un
souterrain peut-être mais ça prend du
temps la principale grande reste le
manque d'accès alors domicile alors
qu'en est-il réellement les voies seront
doublées entre la RN12 au sud et la RD11
au niveau du rond-point du petit
Saint-Cloud le long de cette deux fois
de voix les carrefours seront aménagés
les giratoires du petit Saint-Cloud et
de Jules Régnier seront dénivelés
idem pour ceux du pressoir et négatines
qui seront en plus regroupés en un seul
rond-point le GR on sera rétabli par une
passerelle réservée aux piétons et aux
cyclistes enfin la piste cyclable sera
déplacée et rallongé pour rejoindre le
quartier de la clef Saint-Pierre le
projet devrait coûter près de 80
millions d'euros les travaux
préparatoires ont déjà commencé le
chantier routier débutera quant à lui en
janvier pour une durée minimum de 18
mois
et puisque nous parlons de travaux
l'avenue du pas du lac à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui s'est refait
une beauté durant les vacances vous
l'avez sans doute constaté de moi de
fermeture complète pour le pont qui
enjambe la voie ferrée avec des
déviations une réouverture au début de
cette semaine afin de mener à terme un
chantier d'embellissement et de
sécurisation à l'objectif est de
permettre aux circulations douces de se
développer alors je le maire de la
verrière qui est toujours en plateau il
y a un autre pont on va rester dans les
chantiers les travaux à venir pour les
prochains mois un pont qui va connaître
des réaménagements cela concerne la
commune de La Verrière c'est le pont
Schuller qui est régulièrement
embouteillé c'est un pont qui lui
enjambe la nationale 10 en direction de
Maurepas Maurepas qui d'ailleurs ce soir
organise une réunion publique
d'informations à l'hôtel de ville un
projet auquel vous êtes associé une
réunion publique aura lieu dans votre
commune ce sera le 11 septembre à 20h
oscara B vous attendez quoi de ce
chantier à quoi le futur pont pourra
ressembler
c'est effectivement un projet que nous
défendons depuis très longtemps avec la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin nous l'avons porté parce
que il
ne sert pas aux habitants de La Verrière
c'est très clairement les habitants de
d'Élancourt de Maurepas vont bénéficier
d'un aménagement routier qui leur
facilitera l'accès à la gare et aux
stationnement et qui fasse valorisera
surtout le déplacement des bus et donc
on espère qu'effectivement les habitants
de ce secteur prendront plus facilement
le bus les sons plus facilement la
voiture à la maison et donc soulageront
à la fois les stationnements les
parkings et les circulations donc c'est
pour nous la verrière c'est la
sécurisation des abords de la gare on
est toujours sur des risques
accidentogènes importants sur ce secteur
là c'est évidemment fluidifier donc
notre petite zone d'activité que nous
souhaitons redynamiser ces aménagements
vont contribuer à participer à la
redynamisation de la zone d'activité et
puis pour nous c'est une des étapes du
projet de réaménagement l'ensemble du
secteur avec le carrefour d'Amadou donne
et l'entrée exactement un peu mal en
fonction de leur situation dans le
département c'est par ce chemin là qu'on
accepte principalement la commune de La
Verrière exactement voilà c'est l'entrée
de la verrière c'est l'entrée de
l'agglomération c'est l'entrée ouest de
l'agglomération c'est une entrée
importante et aujourd'hui elle est très
compliquée arriver à La Verrière par le
ponchouleur et le Malmed me donne et un
exercice et extrêmement difficile les
verrières Rouen en général utilisent le
téléphone portable pour piloter leur
visiteurs jusqu'à leur habitation
normalement il y aura forcément comme
pour tous les travaux des désagréments
pour les usagers vous allez veiller à ce
que ce soit au minimum on l'imagine ça
fait partie du cahier des charges bien
sûr donc la communauté d'agglomération
qui est maître d'ouvrage intègre tous
ces éléments pour qu'on puisse continuer
de circuler mais on sait faire
aujourd'hui ce genre de grands travaux
surtout que le pont était prêt à
accueillir un nouveau tablier et donc
les travaux sont somme toutes
importantes mais pourront être réalisés
en maintenant la circulation de réunion
publique une ce soir à Maurepas ce
mercredi soir et puis l'autre ce sera le
11 septembre à La Verrière nous en
parlerons demain dans une prochaine
édition du journal on quitte ce pont je
suis l'air une nouvelle fois vous avez
interpellé l'État pour obtenir des
moyens à la fin de l'été nouvelle fois
car vous l'aviez déjà fait l'été dernier
lors des émeutes qui s'étaient déroulés
à Trappes qui avait touché une partie
aussi de votre commune vous parlez
désintérêts on va résumer ça comme ça du
gouvernement pour la commune pour la
politique que vous menez cette fois-ci
c'est une agression fin août qui a été
la goutte de trop on peut peut-être
revenir sur cette agression sur cette
personne malvoyante qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à la fin du mois d'août dans la
commune alors ça patte de lien ça pas de
lien nous avions interpellé l'État sur
avant et sur un autre sujet mais on l'a
refait évidemment cette agression il y a
une personne malvoyante que nous
connaissons bien dans la ville qui est
installé depuis longtemps qui a été
effectivement agressé à qui on a
soutirait de l'argent dans un
distributeur automatique et donc une
agression particulièrement odieuse
et évidemment nous sommes en rapport
avec la police pour que la lumière soit
faite sur cette affaire et qu'on puisse
interpeller les responsables des
agressions de même nature avait
d'ailleurs eu lieu cet été dans
plusieurs communes de la région
parisienne donc c'est pas spécifique sur
votre colonne ou véritablement c'est un
problème récurrent vous demandez des
moyens de police pour des opérations
dans le secteur d'Orly Park de la gare
plus près non ce sont des des faits
ponctuels heureusement par contre il est
vrai que sur le secteur de la gare nous
sommes confrontés à une situation qui
est pas acceptable de de trafic de
perturbation
qui gênent le le fonctionnement du
centre commercial qui gêne la population
qui met en insécurité donc notre
dispositif de vidéoprotection qui est en
cours d'installation le chantier a
démarré va contribuer le travail que
nous ont avec la police devrait y
contribuer mais il est vrai que nous
faisons partie des communes et des
collectivités qui réclamont
effectivement les moyens de police
nécessairement pas les moyens de police
évidemment le commissariat
j'aimerais bien que le commissariat
d'Élancourt soit renforcé en
objectif il a déjà été mais je pense
qu'il y a encore des choses à faire de
manière à ce que le travail efficace que
nous conduisons avec le commissaire de
police on se voit régulièrement nos
coordonnons nos actions nous avons un
CSPD un des plus actif du département
nous le réunissons encore dans 15 jours
donc nous avons un vrai travail de
concertation mais face aux
problématiques aujourd'hui liées à la
tranquillité il faut plus de moyens une
meilleure coordination et effectivement
un travail en amont un travail social
auprès des populations les plus en
difficulté vous n'avez pas décidé de
mener une politique sécuritaire pas du
tout c'est pas du tout c'est un élément
d'une politique plus générale
l'interpellation que nous avons faite
auprès de l'État c'est par contre c'est
effectivement le risque de retrait des
cités horsipares que de la géographie
prioritaire et donc la perte de moyens
extrêmement important à un moment où par
ailleurs nous avons la réforme des rites
scolaires que nous avons évoqué qui nous
coûte et par ailleurs l'État a décidé de
baisser les dotations collectivités donc
nous sommes aujourd'hui au bord de
l'étranglement et galaxie alors que les
problèmes des populations de nos
quartiers augmentent chômage des
quartiers prioritaires justement pour
préciser les choses ça représente quoi
comme budget qui est versé par l'État
pour aider ces quartiers là est-ce que
vous allez perdre aussi puisque vous
l'avez dit il y a une partie de la ville
de la géographie de la ville qui ne fera
plus partie des quartiers dix
prioritaires parce que l'État
régulièrement redéfinit les périmètres à
travers la France exactement aujourd'hui
c'est difficile de savoir ce que nous
allons perdre parce que c'est pas que
l'État mais par exemple le Conseil
général nous verse la caisse de location
familiale d'autres le conseil régional
nous verse parce que nous sommes en
géographie prioritaire des aides et
subventions
aujourd'hui au bas mot c'est 200 à
300.000 euros d'enjeux pour notre
collectivité ce qui est énorme à
l'échelle de notre commune ça pourrait
être éventuellement plus mais c'est
aussi toute une dynamique avec les les
acteurs qui risquent d'être mis à défaut
donc pour nous c'est le retrait de la
moitié de nos habitants nous avions
aujourd'hui 70% de nos habitations qui
étaient en géographie prioritaire seul
le bois de l'étang serait maintenu mais
nous avons bon espoir que nous avons
lancé une campagne pétition imaginez en
quelques semaines en plein été en plein
mois de juillet nous avons eu 1000
signatures pour une commune de 6000
habitants donc c'est dire d'ailleurs que
les citoyens comprennent bien les enjeux
et participent à la défense des intérêts
de leur commune quand ceux-ci sont
touchés concernés justement ces citoyens
nous sommes allés les rencontrer pour
voir s'ils se sentait en sécurité dans
leur ville la question peut surprendre
mais vu les problèmes qui sont
rencontrés les l et légitimes êtes-vous
en sécurité dans votre ville c'est la
question que nous avons posée à quelques
variées
moi j'ai fait aucun souci
les jeunes il suffit de leur parler ils
sont tranquilles
aucun souci en général ça va il y a pas
de souci de mon coin oui sinon pas
forcément dans le centre côté gare
voilà il y a souvent des voitures quand
même
brûlées et
quelques personnes qui traînent un peu
donc je pense qu'on sortit de gare c'est
on n'est pas pas très rassuré il y a
toujours les mêmes problèmes c'est
partout pareil mais sinon à la VR moi je
me sens tout à fait en sécurité pas du
tout le soir on entend les voitures qui
crament les jeunes qui hurlent
en 20 ans c'est devenu pire en pire ma
petite voisine si c'est qui fait qui
s'est fait agresser à la Banque Postale
personne qui sont malgré tout inquiète
ça reflète le sentiment que vous en avez
d'abord entendu plus de gens qui se
sentaient rassurés oui mais c'est
l'ambiance générale il faut voir que
aujourd'hui dans notre pays le sentiment
d'insécurité n'est pas que de
l'insécurité liée à la tranquillité
c'est un problème d'insécurité
économique un problème d'insécurité
sociale et l'ensemble que combiné donne
effectivement pour notre population des
craintes et une vision quelquefois un
peu négative de leur environnement donc
d'où la nécessité d'être extrêmement
réactive présent d'accompagner et
d'expliquer et d'expliquer aussi mais la
verrière n'est pas plus insécure que la
commune des longs cours ou que la
commune de Guyancourt la sécurité c'est
véritablement quelque chose qui est
important pour les citoyens au quotidien
ça fait partie forcément de la dernière
campagne des municipales lui proposant
avait fait l'un de ses points forts de
sa campagne autour de ça Nicolas
Dainville qui siège au conseil municipal
dans l'opposition nous l'avons rencontré
voici ce qu'il pense de la question de
la sécurité vous pourrez bien sûr lui
répondre
un climat de peur qui est
inacceptable et qui est de moins en
moins tolérable les habitants ils en ont
ras-le-bol il y a eu des actes
d'agression dans le tunnel souterrain
sous la gare au centre commercial dans
les halls d'immeubles dans les caves
nous on demande des actions d'urgence
nous on voudrait plus de policiers
municipaux on a que trois policiers
aujourd'hui on aimerait bien doubler le
nombre de policiers municipaux plus de
présence également de ces policiers qui
soient pas uniquement dédiés à la
verbalisation ou à la circulation mais
aussi à la prévention et puis une
présence de terrain y compris la nuit
c'est fondamental si on veut rétablir un
climat de sécurité dans notre ville
votre opposant de droite qui vous
demande plus de policiers municipaux
c'est envisageable écoutez mon opposant
de droite un discours contradictoire
puisqu'il soutient toutes les politiques
d'austérité la baisse des moyens pour
les collectivités et en même temps il
demande plus de dépenses communales donc
il faut organiser
majorité et des budgets encore il n'est
pas là pour répondre j'imagine
je crois je crois pas que la question
soit les interventions de police
municipales ce n'est pas de la vocation
de la police municipale d'intervenir sur
des actes de cette nature la police
municipale contribue à la tranquillité
par là il parle de verbalisation la
police municipale vous savez sur
l'action principale c'est les conflits
voisinage intervient beaucoup le sur ces
questions là dans les cités dans les
zones pavillonnaires et autres sur la
circulation la prévention par contre le
travail de coordination ça relève de la
police nationale et donc c'est
effectivement la police nationale qui
doit avoir ses moyens adaptés pas
simplement renforcé mais adapté aux
formes nouvelles de délinquance quand à
la description qui fait vous voyez bien
qu'elle n'est pas tout à fait en accord
avec ce que les verrières soient disent
ils passent peut-être pas assez de temps
la verrière est beaucoup plus tranquille
qui ne veut bien le dire mais la
situation je comprends les
préoccupations des habitants et nous
n'avons pas attendu évidemment
l'opposition
pour développer cet été nous avions par
exemple des équipes sur le terrain
jusqu'à 3h du matin de policiers
municipaux ou des gens qui ont été
rappelés en renfort pour des effectifs
de médiateurs que nous avons mobilisés
pour assurer une présence autour de nos
sociétés personnes
ça dépend des moments puisqu'on essaie
d'adapter vous savez ça coûte très cher
donc il faut adapter donc en fonction
des horaires des weekends nous avons une
présente les commerçants bien appréciés
la population a bien apprécié cette
action nous allons prolonger le temps
que nous puissions trouver des solutions
plus pérennes vous nous dites ce n'est
pas la première fois vous interpellez le
gouvernement vous avez lancé une
pétition aussi le gouvernement qui n'a
pas répondu l'année dernière pourquoi il
vous répondrait cette année et si nous
vous répondent pas comment vous voyez
l'avenir tout simplement dès d'abord les
verriers rois sont très très mobilisés
je l'étal local m'a répondu l'état local
préféré en l'occurrence par le matériel
du préfet soutien de notre proposition
de maintien des moyens pour la verrière
donc j'en ai remercié évidemment donc
nous avons demandé un rendez-vous nous
avions obtenu un rendez-vous avec Madame
malheureusement elle n'est plus ministre
de la Ville donc il faut recommencer nos
demandes de rendez-vous ça ne nous aide
pas ces changements gouvernementaux
au-delà des choix politiques mais et
donc on a bon espoir de se faire
entendre parce que nous sommes depuis 30
ans en politique de la vie nous avons
utilisé de bonnes manières l'argent
public en rénovant nos cités en
construisant des équipements en les
maintenant mettant en place des actions
ça serait vraiment dommage que notre
population soit pénalisée alors qu'elle
est nous avons les revenus les plus bas
de l'agglomération avec trappe mais de
manière incontestable notre population a
des revenus qui sont deux fois et demi
trois fois inférieures à ce voisin de
Bretonneux par exemple c'est on va pas
s'en satisfaire mais c'est une réalité
il faut bien que évidemment dans ces
moments où les collectivités locales ont
moins d'argent nous puissions continuer
d'être accompagnés la communauté
agglomération le député de la
circonscription vous soutiennent alors
la communauté je me suis adressé
évidemment au président de
l'agglomération que je vais voir
à très court terme ils n'ont pas grand
chose à craindre les mondialistes ont
toujours la confiance de Didier
Deschamps mais la situation en club de
certains joueurs pourrait menacer leur
place en sélection réservistes au Brésil
Alexandre Lacazette profite de la
blessure d'Olivier Giroud pour
réintégrer le groupe et il compte bien y
rester comme je l'ai dit de rester déjà
dans le groupe des 23 parce que
j'ai pu être dans le groupe des 30 mais
après
à moyen long terme rester dans le groupe
des 23 et participer à l'Euro 2016
Didier Deschamps appellera les plus
performants et ceux qui jouent dans leur
club cet été Antoine Griezmann a changé
de tunique et de niveau en signant chez
le vice-champion d'Europe l'Atletico de
Madrid recruté pour 30 millions d'euros
les coachonero s'attendent que le
français deviennent une pièce maîtresse
du jeu madrilène mais chez les Bleus il
continue de faire profil bar même après
la retraite de Franck Ribéry qui est
Franco ou non ou que ce soit pour un
autre joueur et tout le monde a ses
responsabilités
et moi je fais pas trop attention sinon
jouer mon jeu et voilà sans me prendre
la tête et à me faire plaisir en dehors
et sur le terrain fin de le pouvoir il y
a pas de pouvoir apprendre sinon voilà
je vais au Dieu et
prendre du plaisir et essayer d'amener
l'équipe de France le plus haut possible
nul doute qu'au stade de France face à
l'Espagne les joueurs titulaires
voudront marquer des points pour leur
avenir en bleu
football toujours mais un autre niveau
et l'encours organisé ce week-end son
premier tournoi des moins de 14 ans des
partenaires de la Joxer à l'occasion
pour les jeunes de défier de futurs
professionnels et puis pour les
entraîneurs de peaufiner leurs réglages
avant la reprise du championnat
tous les yeux sont braqués sur ce
maillot blanc celui des joueurs de la
Joce pour son premier tournoi des
partenaires de la Jia et l'encourt
accueille cette équipe et les jeunes
footballeurs de l'OSC ne sont pas du
tout impressionnés par leur prestigieux
visiteurs du jour voir non on aborde les
matchs comme il faut il y a pas de
pression bon on est là pour montrer
notre niveau et voilà on est là pour
montrer ce qu'on sait faire si les clubs
amateurs ont tout juste repris la
direction du terrain de leur côté les
Bourguignons s'entraînent déjà depuis le
17 août Auxerre vient thaïlencourt pour
valider sa préparation estivale le
championnat pour nous reprend le 13
septembre je crois et donc ça nous
permet de voir un petit peu leur écoute
par rapport à ce qu'on leur a demandé
pendant 15 jours de préparation et voir
un petit peu où on en est quoi il n'y a
que très peu de tournois U14 dans la
région alors qu'en l'agit au cerf se
déplace à Élancourt c'est l'occasion
pour les jeunes joueurs de se montrer
sous les yeux des professionnels je
pense qu'on est plus dans un début
vraiment de début de saison d'accord on
est au début de la saison donc je pense
que c'est un moyen pour tous les
entraîneurs de faire un tour d'horizon
je pense aussi que quelque part pour les
GSR c'est un moyen d'avoir l'oeil aussi
sur sur certains joueurs oui c'est sûr
sans trop de surprises l'AJ Auxerre a
remporté ce premier tournoi 14 devant
Brétigny et Élancourt
c'est une information communica la fin
du mois d'août à partir du 18 février le
vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines va accueillir
les Championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur pisme sur piste Anthony Rech
pour l'instant les tribunes sont vides
mais dans quelques mois elle pourrait
bien entendre raisonner de nombreuses
marseillaises avec l'attribution par
l'UCI des championnats du monde sur
piste 2015 à la France du 18 au 22
février prochain le vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vivra un an
à peine après sa naissance le premier
grand moment de sa jeune vie c'est une
page d'histoire sans fausse modestie
mais quand même quoi organiser en France
un championnat du monde c'est une des
pages de l'histoire d'une fédération qui
est centenaire donc on est des personnes
qui sommes en capacité de porter un
projet comme ça on laissera un moment
donné dans les grands livres d'histoire
de la Fédération cette trace c'est
fabuleux
l'événement majeur du cyclisme sur piste
retourne en France neuf ans après les
Mondiaux de Bordeaux une occasion unique
pour la génération dorée des services
Baugé et Almeida de dominer la planète à
domicile avant les Jeux olympiques de
Rio et dans cette quête l'équipe de
France pourra compter sur le soutien des
5000 personnes que peuvent contenir les
gradins du vélo drone donc faut vraiment
dire à nos au public français soyez là
derrière vos coureurs ils attendent ça
ils attendent d'être vraiment porté par
leur par leur public pour dire ce
chaudron là il était fabuleux et ce
vélodrome national du coup devient une
référence mondiale
au dernier championnat du monde
colombien la France avait décroché
quatre titres dont le triplé historique
de François Pervis et une médaille de
bronze en vitesse par équipe
sport toujours si vous avez envie de
vous essayer au golf jusqu'au aussi
septembre l'espace commercial 50 ans à
Montigny propose une animation gratuite
de 10h à 20h pour vous donner les
premiers conseils des spécialistes du
Golfe des spécialistes du golf
interviennent de l'île de loisirs de
Trappes des cadeaux sont aussi à gagner
les amateurs ont d'ores et déjà testé
leur technique
il faut arriver à se concentrer à être
bien constant dans le geste c'est très
souple tout en étant ferme c'est pas
facile ouais faut juste rester concentré
et puis tirer quoi
non moi au bout de trois fois
c'est très amusant j'ai bien
faire ça parce que c'est super super
bien pour ceux qui veulent comme cette
petite fille poursuivre l'aventure le
golf 5 continents organise deux journées
portes ouvertes ce sera du 12 au 22 et
septembre le 7 8 le journal revient
demain jeudi en direct à 18h pour une
nouvelle édition excellente soirée sur
notre antenne avec un nouveau numéro
pour cette saison de kiosque le magazine
de la culture